du hast sagt paul es könnte sein dass
sollte die spd gewinnen karl lauterbach
der nächste gesundheitsminister werden
wird dann müsste die fdp mit ihm
zusammenarbeiten wenn sie in eine ampel
koalition gehen würde ampelkoalition das
hat fdp chef lindner eigentlich zunächst
ausgeschlossen aber das scheint sich
etwas zu entwickeln wir haben mal was er
zunächst gesagt hatte
ich lese aber das programm und ich kenne
auch saskia esken zu und deshalb sage
ich wenn ich die programme nebeneinander
legen fehlt mir noch die fanta noch die
fantasie
also ich glaube inzwischen einen schönen
inzwischen klingt das ganz anders da war
gleich direkt im anschluss mal rein wenn
es um die ampel geht werden am
wochenende hatte sich sich länder dann
so geäußert
wir werden aufgefordert irgendetwas
auszuschließen
ja wir schließen was aus wir schließen
aus steuererhöhungen wir schließen aus
aufweichung der schuldenbremse wir
schließen aus bürokratismus wir
schließen aus links druck das schließen
wir aus aber wir schließen nicht aus die
ampel so sieht's aus ich glaube dass
christian lindner da viel ehrlicher war
als vor wenigen wochen er sieht dass die
spd momentan zumindest in umfragen vorne
ist und was christian lindner braucht
ist regierungsbeteiligung was er nicht
gebrauchen kann ist dass es so passiert
wie vor vier jahren dass am ende nicht
jamaika schafft nicht die ampel schafft
er muss in die regierung und man sieht
was er nicht zugeben will weil das
natürlich am ende dazu führen könnte
dass leute sagen okay wenn die fdp
wirklich eine ampel macht dann gehen wir
vielleicht doch noch zur cdu deswegen
ist all das was jetzt passiert
wahltaktik aber natürlich würde
christian die ampel gehen natürlich will
er das am ende wenn es diese chance wenn
es diese möglichkeit gibt und natürlich
ist es so dass die partei das
unterstützen wird scholz hat dem ja auch
schon ein paar angebote gemacht klingt
alles ein bisschen bisschen gedämpft da
eigentlich als noch am anfang die beiden
können viel besser als man denken würde
christian lindner eingeladen zum
geburtstag von olaf scholz olaf scholz
hat vorgebaut in den vergangenen wochen
in den vergangenen jahren in den
vergangenen monaten und hat christian
lindner immer wieder eingebunden olaf
scholz hätte niemals gedacht dass er die
chance bekommt als erster möglicherweise
je nachdem wie es ausgeht durch das
rennen zu gehen olaf scholz taktik war
immer zu sagen wenn ich einen guten
zweiten platz erreichen dann habe ich
eine chance dass er jetzt dort steht wo
er steht das hätte er selbst niemals
gedacht interessantes zitat heute von
sigmar gabriel bei gabor steingart
übrigens er wurde darauf angesprochen ob
es eine große strategie war und dann
sagte gabriel ja schon schröder hätte
gesagt wenn etwas gut läuft dann würde
hinterher gesagt man hätte eine
großartige strategie gehabt tatsächlich
sei es nur das total versagen der union
das ist tatsächlich ist es das total
versagen der kandidaten ist es total
versagen von armin laschet ich meine
wenn man sich anschaut wo die union im
januar stand bei mitte dreißig ende 30
prozent und jetzt ist sie bei 23 24 das
zeigt dass der kandidat momentan das
problem ist und wenn sigmar gabriel
schon sagen muss dass ein erfolg ist der
wie man weiß olaf schulz eigentlich
überhaupt gar nicht schätzt dann sieht
man wohin gekommen ist
[Musik]